[Music]
today's question comes from carrie in
texas kerry writes my fiance proposed to
me before we moved across the country
for new jobs we both make over a hundred
grand a year but he has a lot of debt i
don't know how much daddy has because he
hasn't completely shared that with me
yet
i'm debt free with a net worth of 880
000 should we wait until he's debt-free
to get married if not should i ask for a
prenuptial agreement due to the
difference in our financial situations
dave i'll let you handle the pre-nut but
i'm gonna tell carrie don't get married
you all have too many unspoken
conversations y'all need to have there's
some bigger issues going on here man
that's
man that's that's my thought yeah if you
if he won't tell you how much daddy he
has how'd he get
married ever i mean you don't get
married until you got the air cleared on
this
how are you gonna make a human i hear
this all the time dave people tell you
everything they'll tell you this and
that
they'll make babies how much debt does
he have i don't know he didn't want to
talk about it got three kids with him
but i don't know yeah i've made a human
with him but i don't know how much money
he owes mastercard that's ridiculous
yeah you don't do that that's true um so
here's the thing
um
john's right
the number one cause of divorce in north
america today is money fights and money
problems
and um so you've got to get on the same
page about money before you get married
whoever you are
whatever the situation is as a matter of
fact i'll carry it a little bit further
all the data tells us also on the
marriage stats
that um the other three things that
break up marriages are kids how many to
have and how to raise them
are the inmates gonna run the asylum or
are we gonna raise stepford children
um you know we're overly strict or or we
just have a
craziness in the house all the time
whichever it is
um or
do the uh
you know
religion is number three
are you in agreement on religion
christians call that unequally yoked but
are you in agreement on religion
that breaks up marriages like crazy and
the fourth one that breaks up marriages
like crazy is in-laws
how we gonna handle the crazy people on
the extended part of the family because
there is always some crazy people in the
extended part of the family how we gonna
handle that
and if you can have those four
discussions in depth preferably in the
setting of a pre-marriage counselor
money religion
kids and in-laws you get on the same
page on all that in-depth discussions
you have set yourself up for a
statistically
very good chance of a successful
marriage and can i go one step below
that there's talking about those four
issues is really important
creating a
language or an environment
to where not if but when
my
my faith journey looks different now
than it did 20 years ago 25 years ago
when i met sheila what i thought i was
going to how was going to raise kids
looks
different than it does actually having
two of them and one of them's really
mean to me dave
it changes right so how are we going to
have these conversations together as we
roll too but i mean what are the what
are the what are the principles the
guiding values right yes
and so
it's just i mean one of you is way over
here that's right and the other one's
way over there on something you're gonna
struggle you really are it's gonna be an
issue so back to your question though um
so number one you guys have got to sit
down and get on the same page you have
to know everything about his money he
has to know everything about your money
including your fears of having a good
net worth while he doesn't
and that's a good that's a good part of
the money discussion
i do not recommend prenups unless the
difference in the wealth is extreme
yours is borderline if you got a million
dollars and he has a negative half
million dollars of net worth because
he's got a million dollars of student
loan debt and no money you know that's
pretty extreme it's a million and a half
swing
um so you may want to consider it at
that point but it the problem people run
the prenups as if
that is going to protect cause their
relationship to work after they didn't
talk about crap they should have talked
about
and so you're hiding i think how bunkers
that is for hiding behind the prenup is
what most people are doing but now i
will tell you you know like for instance
if i die my wife is gonna be worth
hundreds of millions of dollars she is
now and she would still be and i would
suggest to her that she get a prenup
yeah because she's probably not going to
find her equal if she were to remarried
in uh in wealth and it's dangerous and
it's really not even dangerous for the
person you're marrying
it's all the people that are attached
that are weird
like your crazy uncle comes out of the
uh your his crazy uncle comes out of the
closet once he figures out that
the financial closet once he figures out
that uh
his nephew married a rich girl that's
exactly right he's gonna show up over
there with all these new ideas about a
pizza parlor he wants to open you know
and that's kind of crazy he's gonna slip
and hurt his knee on your back patio
prenup helps with some of that because
you just look at uncle crazy pizza and
go no i ain't anything shit's hurt we
got to prenup and can't touch it so it
helps with running off the crazies and
managing them because they do come out
of the woodwork the more difference that
there is two broke people get together
and other crazies care that's right so
uh but one of them's rich somebody one
of the craziest is all interested now
you know so um and that's what i've you
know i see this with like we work with
pro athletes you know where we work with
uh
music people around nashville and this
kind of stuff and we see that
occasionally so there's an occasion for
that when i first started i would just
say no prenups no matter what but i've
seen enough crazy that i i now am okay
with that in an extreme situation so
yeah you may want to end up with a
prenup but it's the last part of this
entire discussion i want you to close
the discussion with that not open
the discussion with that which means
that you've got all the other work done
then the prenup is going to be in a good
setting
and it's mainly to keep the other people
out not him but don't start a marriage
moving across the country together
when you won't even talk about how much
money you have we don't even move across
the country together we can't even talk
about money you won't talk about how
scared you are of his situation there's
so much unspoken don't start a marriage
with secrets